I moved to the U.S as an immigrant okay
I had the benefit if my parents had to
pay for my initial schooling like if
they had to pay out of pocket for
elementary school or whatever the case
may be that you know my mom wasn't
working at the time my dad was just
starting a job where he didn't make a
lot of money they couldn't have afforded
if that public school said we're going
to charge you right so I immediately got
the benefit of that I've been
extraordinarily fortunate to be able to
build my business and get to where I am
thanks to a whole bunch of things that
everybody paid for through taxes I feel
it's almost like a patriotic thing where
if taxes are properly set and being
spent on the right things I think now my
success which only exists because of
previous taxpayers through all those
programs I mentioned it should go to
help other people who don't have that's
the wrong mindset in my opinion